citizens of reject Nation we are here
for the final hurray Henry cavill's
geralt of Rivia the final episode of The
Witcher season three volume dose Greg
how you doing today
it's like he's here in the room with me
well guys don't forget to hit that like
button if you love Henry Cavill in this
role And subscribe if you are cautiously
optimistic about Liam Hemsworth taking
over and before we hop into this if you
want to secure yourself one final piece
of rejects history toss a coin to the
shopzeroedition.com store where we have
this exclusive Limited Edition ah soda
t-shirt inspired by the Beloved Star
Wars character Ahsoka Tano you only got
to the end of July to pick one up so uh
grab one while they last and uh join the
movement anyway guys last but not least
get yourself a cat and go on over to
patreon.com the real rejects if you
would too would like to enjoy the
entirety of this Witcher episode with us
see everything that doesn't make this
highlight reel it's a lot of fun over
there we've also got several other shows
and films we do reaction highlights
watch alongs for it's a great time but
without further Ado let's have ourselves
a great time with the last two episodes
of The Witcher we're going to do episode
six and seven all together and then do
the finale on its own
let's do this thing
I cannot measure me until we found what
we came to do
now lay down your weapon I need to ask
the boys to persuade you kick his ass
Carol kick his ass some prisoner we're
gonna hear from Andrews after all I see
us as allies
[Music]
series the sunlight Siri where is that
light coming from
excellent
it's good timing
breakfast I was trying to know what you
were doing relevant Jessica you've got
it wrong which part the part where you
feigned affection for me or the part
where you tried to kidnap a young woman
under my care
would make everything easier for us if
she came to Eden yeah I'd be out from
under the extra time and there it is how
can you pick my feelings for you alive
because of this exact situation yeah
you had one job
yeah scared you don't messed up we have
ample evidence of vilgaforter lining
business card so this is a trial no
no
for 12 hours we will intercede with this
idea
kick her ass Jennifer
[Music]
it's one thing the sucker punch somebody
but is do it with magic too
oh [__] and The Crowd Goes Wild
with us
there we will find and fulfill our own
destiny her destiny
nothing
that was resolved quickly
yeah man all you need is a bum rush set
things right Kira Radcliffe why wasn't
she secured because I told them I would
melt their faces if they touch me
nothing here oh we'll see about that we
have accounts of portals bridging this
place in nilfgaard vilga forces portals
vilga ports
as in a natural fog in the bay what do
you mean someone's using magic to
conceal ships don't you see it's a
redanian army kick that fox ass could
we've assorted girls
let's go break The Binding spell she
spooned you for what you had to do at
sudden Hill we're moving closer
shut him up
that guy's gonna get it
[Music]
oh damn I'll just tell you where we've
taken her
to my fist I've got 50 men coming on
those boats are barber surgeon
ah girl could take 50 men
[Music]
no
no it's like a magic the Gathering game
happening around them we'll take it from
here to here
don't ever come back here that's her
leaving her with I would murder her
you're expelled we can
we can Indians out if we unite our chaos
and trap them in the tunnels the square
tale will enter this place and Burn It
To The Ground in the name of the White
Flame oh no
what are you talking
put it together to say ah come on you're
the most brilliant of them this is our
home no desire
this is your home I have my own aims and
they no longer include you I got an
apartment
struggable with this Pride was easy to
set up and
your undying trust were easy to fall I
liked you man kill him
please
do not do this
kill him why are you just standing there
this could be interesting
oh no
today we reclaim our two and we bring
the Elder Blood Prince
home
and then we read the Half-Blood Prince
so metal you will never
take
now
guys use your like ultimate magic power
and just murder them
it's got to be like a spell you can do
to just like sweep the whole room yeah
he always does
[Applause]
[Music]
that was wicked ABS Africa oh man
rest in peace all that guy did was
defend his sister Philip Andrew
constantly defending a sister
[Music]
oh frangila how could you
know
you've gotta fight no time to grieve
[Music]
ment
in hell
what's up
we're almost at Stables
this guy my man
I have no master you sure about that I'm
going to remove my sword
[Music]
back away
right by the camera
that was resolve fast yep that ass Yep
they're all searching for you Siri we
have to get off this island it's lost
yeah
[Music]
I do like the way this episode is shot
it's a lot of moving and shots
definitely a lot of mood
really don't like this guy
did we just become best friends
oh damn
[Music]
good stunts too
kill them all yes dread let that let
that anger out I'm not even rooting for
any side I just want Bloodshed the doors
are magic concealed
not anymore yeah there's just like
non-stop tracking shots in this episode
all right great great time to have a
heart attack you pansy yeah damn it
Tilda Swinton Mage we only wanted to
stop vilga Force you've made your choice
traitors punish us tomorrow it's our
home let us fight with you
for you Dumbledore's army man they're
just like wrapping up plots and changing
plots so fast you're gonna be a smooth
transition to Liam Hemsworth I'm telling
you
it's too late no it isn't
[Music]
snap out of it to Sarah
what are you doing to say she's gonna
jump off the roof rewind time oh that
could work
[Music]
that must hurt so bad to remove an era
especially because you're like ripping
stuff with the shape of the heads off
[Music]
yeah okay
all the hugs
I can fix this
damn she got boromired [__] shooter like
50 arrows make sure that one's dead
she's going into the speed force
what's wrong again
a span of lost Resort got my life in two
pieces
no she has no choice
Destiny practice together
I am your density
[Music]
oh my daughter
I'm simply no longer confined here you
know it is amazing what you can do when
you think for yourself
your sheeple there's a good chance the
girl has already fled the building take
a search party and go to say his life's
mine ah dude you guys should team up God
this could hear a guy is so annoying
[Applause]
no one
what will this last resort spell do it's
gonna be like a complete Annihilation
just Total Wipeout and maybe it'll just
pull in like a giant bolt of lightning
and Fry everyone
it's like an electrical current what's
happening it's alive
oh damn she's like storm yeah
oh it's just gonna wipe out everyone
yeah
badass
oh
the book from The Mummy
this son of a [__] thank you for the
book but it's not the only thing I want
I'll see you soon
oh no
no damn it man
what do you call the Spy mask that when
all of this spies have fled a master
he's dead
I don't know what the other way yeah
there you go Hedwig
dude that owl is your ride or die we
must move
to say is use emails as Thunder
he will kill anyone She lays eyes on
pick him up by the other side
not until we get some distance from tall
Lara
enjoy pain yeah that's what I was
thinking oh fair enough kinky all right
very cool I need to get down there
my God geralt I swear to God if you do
not murder this guy
to my homie band he's haunting my
nightmares ever since
I'm not afraid of him anymore I'm Not
Afraid right Siri
I do not wish to fight you pick it up
be a man in the attacking sintra when I
took you I did everything I was asked
with no hesitation but now I can't stop
asking questions I can't give you back
the life I stole
whoa my life is yours
take it
everything from me I know take this
place
and may yours be the last face I see in
this world
no the lying
who has the power to move the world
I owe you that oh my God murder him
please
nah make him your man servant forgive me
go
never mind don't kill me yeah I could be
I could be useful right now actually
[Music]
she is aging rapidly fast you know you
really should take breaks so that your
hair doesn't get fried though no
God damn it
you will not take what his ass she can
deflect she's out you have no choice
I'll show you the rape of course
I'll buy you some time I've been waiting
for this moment all my life set them
Ablaze everyone's just dabbling in Fire
magic when they're not supposed to help
me move this
a well-timed creature battle is no one
concerned about yaskir
I thought about it since the first scene
I can help you get lost always found go
who's he gonna fight uh vilgaforts maybe
or a beast I think it's got to be a
beast just some random Beast
[Music]
[Applause]
so we have an epilogue then
a man
the Dengue mall that draws the plague
to a close
or is it faint
this guy's full-on villainy now I know
he's like full mustache twirling and
there is no way out
I'm glad to hear it
reach it you're a wise man geralt that
he is I grow tired of asking and I grow
tired of answering I will not be your
partner
I will not join your fight this q a is
over arrogance will be your undoing
[Music]
God everyone just wants to recruit Carol
today
you like my stuff
do you want to touch it
know what the hardest part was knowing I
could take any life if
can imagine today I hold back no more
great choreography damn yeah
Abomination wow
oh no she's gonna need some serious hair
dye
no magic will return my hair to its
natural Auburn
[Music]
peace yes make a friend of this pain I
get onto premiere
today
ouch
oh you begin your new life that's my
warning
oh this is supposed to be a lesson
oh thank you sir man I have another
I shall see you later
one day perhaps
all right let him live left him with the
shame of defeat
really there wasn't I guess so there's
got to be some magic residue on that
shattered his spinal cord in a way
is it a monolith
touch it what are you trying to tell me
[Music]
well into the spider-verse
what are you doing
what you're playing with sirilla
can't tap into the Multiverse
Siri is all powerful
and there's omnipotent as the crashing
waves
rolled
can you hear me
oh everyone gather around
[Music]
tearing it all down for the monolith
oh damn
not bad that was a really fun cool
episode guys it was let's watch the next
one
all right jumping right in episode three
by seven
cool sigil too I want that on a necklace
something going on I came looking for my
guards I thought I'd seen the last of
you that was the plan
this might have been more effective if
the very last time wasn't them together
yeah he immediately finds him
Philippine the only one scheming at
founded they suspect Phil before it's
conspired with no God and any of our
Emirates took the whole continent by
surprise we have to get you out of it
again it looks so Angelic in that light
it will get you as far as oxenford I had
some friends there with a safe house
give them this we'll get you to the
capital come with me then come with me
now did you find out first I saw that
Tower explode felt it like a Shockwave
probably been transported to another
dimension
they're friends now you son of a [__]
[Music]
we're back in Brooklyn Forest apparently
is
[Music]
the people that I think Siri was within
the first season yeah
[Music]
it is not a waste when bled your friend
the Sorceress left this for you is
fantastic makeup
pop it back in
a normal desert
yeah what is all that sound bouncing off
of
oops I just had the phone
okay taught her how to do that
this is one of the most excruciating
looking things as per movies and shows
comment below if you've ever had your
arm popped out of the socket
wow
hello
okay make friends with the frem and
learn to ride the sand worm
this does look excruciating
[Music]
it's that headache cream they sell on TV
soldiers
yeah the hand's been in the sand coconut
oil
someone will pick it up John take your
clue with you
[Applause]
[Music]
I would love it if she just died
it's right here
oh no I how is that possible this is all
the Mirage she's trapped in a giant
hourglass
there's someone out but show yourself I
will find you and follow you right out
of this [__] desert follow your
[Music]
s
Glycerine
isolated horror movies
this is really thick water they give to
people who have trouble swallowing
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
wait come back so I can get you
food this is gonna be good
can't wait for Mama and lizard to come
out that's certainly no way for a
princess to behave
the people in your life they all want to
do their best by you but it's not enough
I'm afraid
don't pay stupid you know this what a
terrible vision
are you saying all this I can only
imagine how relieved Garrett was to see
you run into that Tower
abandoned me you went on that boat and
you didn't take me with you
oh
this conversation's over
[Music]
that's cruel I think I have the power to
change things you're not the first
person to feel that way but you my
friend you could be
maybe you're the first one who can
actually make those changes what is the
point of this I'm not sure yet
to slow the pace down and make us Wonder
[Music]
horse can lead you to water but it can't
force you to drink
chocolate milk that's what good leaders
do they stand up to the enemy you've
hidden yourself away all this time
you led into a cycle of violence you let
history repeat itself there you go
that's how you stand up do you really
think that someone like you to change
things where countless other than a fail
failed even forming your own identity
punch that kalanthi rock I should have
been Queen but when my father denied me
my Royal Destiny I decided to Rally the
common folk and with their help I took
back what was rightfully mine
her I've heard that story fitting since
in the end they tied me to stake and
burned me alive
oh damn hey stop shaming myself for what
I could not control you want to change
the system princess cirilla I mean yeah
Burn It To The Ground
then create a new system and someone
else will burn that to the ground
please don't ride I can sense something
wowie no
[Music]
use it as a shield
damn
now eat it no
that's messed up that's heartbreaking
[Music]
oh buddy come on now we have to move to
survive
all right that did help thank you for
the bandage
take a look now
right here
[Music]
gotten better at all
I'm not helpless but there is nothing
out there I have nothing to draw from I
thought you said magic is everywhere
get back to that tree where the horse
took you with the water it's forbidden
by who Jennifer said it's dangerous this
is one good thing you can do with your
power otherwise this creature your
friend will die I mean there's no
question about it use it
this is the whole point the elf has set
all this up maybe just to get a powerful
fire user on hand
[Applause]
oh the fire dude just cauterized the
wound I guess so then maybe we can Flex
it just a little bit so that it like
chars up whatever poisonous aspect might
be in there
let's rock and roll I'm back 100 percent
history repeating itself except isn't a
curse
gift one they either wish to use you for
or destroy you for it can be a gift
depending on how you wield it you will
change everything
having fun into the
embrace the flyer you are The Keeper of
the El Pollo Loco Flame
is righteous your revenge is
you always be their Pawn not yes gear
need anyone no I feel the pleasure
frame this is your power
imagine
I don't want it I don't want it please
it's hard all right can you be sure
she's the one have you seen many an
action here at green eyed wolf on the
edge of the desert your [__] knob
head this is the girl he's looking for
you two pick her up the Unicorn brought
them here traitor I'm a friend of geralt
the white wolf Queen blade please at
Saturday came in
hmm
amen
is he making this up
Maybe
[Music]
well
nope it's classic lore song but he knows
their language headers are do he needs
you don't look behind Now do for him
what you just did for all of us that's
just Village outside robofin and they
paste it
willing to kill everyone to find her
she's apparently at work the emperor
announced the celebration she's on her
way to know
it's all the medicine I needed
rage Witcher Montage training montage
damn
I wanted that training montage
yep
no we made it I think that was hurting
over the credits maybe was it sounded
kind of like your back could be wrong
Freya Allen
well in her capture she will unleash her
power
bigger and brighter than ever before
and then there'll be like geralt through
Jennifer to be like Siri calm down and
hugs her before she fully succumbs to
the dark side yeah and then from there
she'll have a perfect balance of how to
use the powers this is paced weirdly the
first episode of this was a banger of a
action set piece with some fast-moving
plot turns and changes and some
resolution and Cliffhangers
this is kind of just moving it was like
all right this is fast but it's
entertaining and it's got some great
visuals and some awesome camera work and
um I I really enjoyed it and then the
second episode
Netflix designs are shows to be binge
but I don't really feel like this was a
great Conor and to watch these two
immediately back to back because then
the second episode goes now let's really
slow this [__] down
so much let's get contemplative yeah
let's get some existential pondering
dread going on here let's get opaque and
sort of vague about stuff yeah with uh
your stranded isolated uh you know the
seeing into the psyche with
cliche confrontations
other than the the elf coming into The
Fray and that was I still enjoyed it
though I mean admittedly it was a little
boring at first but then it got more
interesting as a progress once I started
getting a sense of where it was going uh
uh I like the bond with the Unicorn I
liked uh everything about uh her coming
into her own power and her own Identity
or she's being stripped down to the pain
that she is and it seems like that was
the temptation of it all of being lost
here in the desert and being stripped to
such a point where she would have to
give in in order to survive but she
doesn't ultimately give him but I bet
she'll give him a tiny bit when it comes
down to it in the final moments here
when reunited with Daddy and nilfgaard
so yeah I think there's some interesting
plot points to come but
um you know like it was just it was it
was a cool just go it was still like
looked good and I I really loved her
performance there like this was her
episode and she completely carried the
entire thing I like the visuals of the
creatures there yeah that was pretty
awesome to see
and yeah so it's like contemplative
qualities are neat and all uh I just
think it's a little it's Pace a little
funny and I think it could have used
some inner cutting yes between this and
something else
just geralt going no no I can't move I
mean you could have maybe intercut like
yeah trying to get it well yeah in
Jennifer too but I mean yeah that's
something like I don't know I respect on
one hand the choice to keep it all
isolated like it does kind of
force you to to sort of
I don't know it slightly kind of cuts
through everything and it's like oh okay
like we're really focusing on this and
it grabs your attention that way but it
is also yeah such a contrast of pace
since like the first episode had all
this like crazy fight choreography and
all these like really fluid moving shots
and things like that and like you said
so many things are coming to a head or
you know the sixth episode first of this
chunk uh and then yeah here I like the
it seemed appropriate that the
penultimate episode of this installment
should be like heavily dedicated to
series is because everything going on
hinges so heavily on her but yeah it's
like this could have been more unique
and I still don't know how like the wild
Hunt is gonna figure into all this like
I thought we were gonna get back to some
of that this episode and uh you know we
got one episode to touch back on that if
we're even gonna do it this season
uh and two knowing that the next episode
will be the last one for Henry Cavill it
is sort of like well now that episode
has to deliver on you know some great
moments to send him off with because the
previous episode certainly showed off
his physical abilities with a lot of
really cool fights and there are a
couple moments where you know the Mages
are arguing with dijkstra's people and
he's just in the middle being like guys
this fog is rolling in like your shit's
about to hit the fan you guys better
figure out your minds
um but yeah like it seems like even
still the last episode has a lot to
accomplish here it was nice to go back
to Brooklyn forest and see those uh I
forget what their race of people is
called but to see them again the
beautiful makeups as you pointed out and
the designs it's nice to get some
slight Witcher ring in that there was a
creature for her to bludgeon to death
I just there's so many characters and I
only care about like two
yeah like two to three I recognize a lot
of people and everybody's like oh yeah
you
you know you're all right I guess like
that was the one thing about the battle
artuza was I I thought it was a cool
looking battle with some very neat
cinematography and some good use of
environment uh like I like to Saya uh I
do like to say uh I don't know if I'd be
heartbroken if to say it died or
something but I'd like to say uh I was
gripped in her big moment yeah and I
thought they did a great job at
reestablishing biblical forts as his
true biblical Force he's a true Force
here where you know like whooping
Daryl's ass you're like okay yeah this
guy's a real Contender he's a real
villain because before I I never always
got the impression like I'm sure if him
and girl went Toe to Toe girl will whoop
his ass and then you see him in battle
and him like dropping hints like I've
I've been holding back my power
and you see that oh he's not just a
great Mage but he's also a fantastic
Warrior too I thought it was an awesome
uh way to establish him as like okay he
is a formidable threat
just overall the battle between the
elves where you don't really like the
season didn't do much for character
development for the elves no like at all
to the point where it got to that battle
and the brother dying like the brother
just always shows up to be like oh my
sister I can't remember my sister you
know I'm just not there's there's not
much substance or Nuance really given so
when he died it was like a great visual
where it's the zooming in shot where she
looks all normal he steps in front
obvious sacrifice and coming explosion
she's covered in his blood and guts
which was a really cool moment uh but it
really did hit me of as much as cool as
the visuals are here I don't really have
an emotional attachment or a vested
interest in any one's side here to the
point where it's just making for like
fun cool observation uh but I I don't
really feel uh apparel because I don't
really care about anyone here
it's been such a build up though too to
this fight that by the time we got here
it was like
uh all right I I I I I just it's been
like uh some political talk but nothing
to really make me really care about the
characters unless I'm really factoring
and [__] from the previous season well
it seems like they're almost wholesale
using season two as all of the
motivation and fleshing for the elves
like you get a little more you get a
little expander on rodania and like
dextra and them in this season that
helps some and then you have like
yennefer's struggles with what is going
on within the Brotherhood and I feel
like those are kind of the biggest
pieces of you know like context to sink
your teeth into and then a lot of other
things happen very fast and kind of ride
off your knowledge of who people have
been in the past like yeah it seems like
in trying to collide so many things and
to make it feel like man just every
force is closing in to get serious like
I think there's yeah there's stuff you
could have done in the text of this
season to make those things feel much
more graceful and like you can feel the
weight of all these uh people colliding
versus just feeling the momentum the
Collide and the collapse yeah you know
yeah because they're like oh wow Man
compared to just falling apart wrecked
there too and they got a monolith here
and I've and I'm and it just keeps
coming back to the emotional Association
for me of I don't know why I don't care
now
I don't know what it is I don't I don't
feel like that should be something that
that takes a heavy toll on the heart in
some capacity and for you guys if it
does good good I'm glad you're getting
that loss uh that that's a great that's
a great thing to feel the epicness of
that
uh
like I said it's it's I I'm just finding
myself just sort of kept at a distance
and an appreciation of things especially
on technical scales uh but in terms of
Storytelling the show's been
progressively losing me
yeah I mean I feel like in the previous
Seasons I can remember like what eratusa
means and like you know spending
officials used to spend much more time
places and now
yeah you don't really get to kind of
again it's all writing off your memory
because it's a place that certainly has
its shadowy you know murky problematic
details but it's also home to so many
people it's the place where so many
people come of age and unlock their
power and here it just feels like a one
of many places people are arguing and
fighting yeah and I I don't know you
don't need to re-establish everything
and I know Season Two was a change from
season one but I remember like Care More
in Falling seemed to be like a pretty
impactful event and so for as important
as aratuza has been yeah it's like they
they mostly gripped with like a really
good immediacy and a good sort of
immediate flavor but uh I don't know
even with the service they do pay to the
actual sort of like reason this is all
happening you don't really feel very
connected to it yeah that's the word
connected like frangila killing her
uncle
yes okay and I haven't seen her in a
while like she's the last time I saw her
she like you know Broke Free and and
what has like one meeting with somebody
or other I think there's a lot of
service givenika here and maybe he's
like really important in the books but I
just don't like him uh I I don't and I
think there's this thing where the show
has been trying to make you go I hope
there's a turn for this guy I hope
there's a Redemption for this guy or
something to making me
complex
interesting character and I'm like I
just think he's annoying I think it's a
really annoying frustrating character
and not in a complimentary way I was
just like just kill this guy get him out
of the show he's so frustrating
um and never in a way where I ever find
myself rooting for this guy in in any
sort of Direction you know so him even
coming to this moment of yes I it's my
fault Siri I've been waiting for this
and him willing to give his life
uh was like
I don't know I don't feel like there's
any real true catharsis or reward to
this moment here for foreign
[Music]
and like they kill off they got rants
here too in like half a second yeah
that's what I mean all that build up
with him where he was never really a
threatening guy in this whole season and
then he's just like he's often in a
second well when they recast him it just
feels like they everyone checked out on
that character yeah like even the actor
no shade but even the actor kind of
seemed to
have this air of like yeah I'm not going
to be here long
ER yeah for through that I guess you
must have telepathically done and uh
yeah telekinetically yeah some magical
mumbo jumbo to throw the sword yeah
um it's weird it's like they'll have
scenes that feel like they should be
that have all the ingredients to equate
to that rousing quality but there was
just some kind of magic about the first
and some aspects of the second scene
like the second season again gets a bit
more modern in its sensibility and
certainly in its tone of dialogue but I
feel like both of those at least manage
to again make the map feel fleshed out
and pay enough service to the actual
substance versus the action to like at
least
I don't know give everybody enough
flavor that you could differentiate and
kind of keep track and care to do so
whereas now it feels sort of like you
know geralt Jennifer and Syria are sort
of like as long as you got track of them
you know you'll kind of be fine and even
with them I like them being the family I
like that that's what they have to fight
for however a lot of that stuff does
feel very sort of
you know people really like that I can
just feel some kind of like you know
meeting of yeah of the non-like writers
room being like people this this family
of dynamic is really tracking well can
we like you know make that the
foreground of things and just like I
don't know there's a sentimentality they
apply to that that I don't begrudge but
that doesn't feel complete and so it
feels a little I don't know shallow or
something about well also the other the
other character the messed up face lady
just like
who's been such a threat
yeah it just happens like so fast it's
happening so fast and even the just the
justification for the
um I'm forgetting everyone's name but
bald guy who was stoic in the last
season but is now like weirdly emotional
yeah yeah he him surviving in that
moment
it was just such an obvious moment like
okay he's obviously gonna survive
because this one Mage is like dragging
the [__] out yeah
um but I just I think there's some like
cliche choices with an interesting
visual once in a while with the acting
everyone seems really committed even
Henry Cavill uh everyone seems really
committed still through performance and
I and I think the performances from our
from I think the women are actually like
the standout performers to all of them
100 uh like Jennifer
and Syria are have been great and I love
the struggle that she brought to her
performance in the second episode
and uh yeah the existential qualities of
it but at the same time it is like
this does kind of drag a little bit yeah
yeah it's like there's I don't know the
levels are sort of all off because yeah
then it stunts the fantasy stuff because
then you're just sort of trying to
orient yourself to it and then when they
do check back into politics you're like
okay I'm a little lost now well the
writing of the dialogue and the moments
in the desert or just like this is the
about as cliche as it gets for this
genre this is for for this story of
Wanderer and loss and confronting demons
from your past yeah yes it's so cliche
here's a core trauma for you now you
gotta push through it and tell it off in
this beloved person in your memory is
now yelling cliches at you yeah now
healing this unicorn is also going to be
a metaphorical Act of finding your way
back to you know being on the road to
recovery yourself
or something yeah it was it's lost some
of that magic and even like when it came
to yaskir and the brother
I forget everyone's name uh yes Kieran
the brother
it's like all right you haven't seen
them in a couple episodes
and they're having a Fallout right at
the beginning okay Fallout got it and in
the next episode that they try to treat
it like there's been a distance between
them and the time has passed and I'm
like but the last time I saw you guys
you it was you guys together yeah you
know yeah so it's like it feels like
he's immediately found him conveniently
rather than yeah the cell is like making
you like invested enough that you're not
thinking of that yeah because there's a
quality that this part of the season has
been highlighting to me it feels like
one of those moments where it's like
they've almost removed everything but
the most essential beats of each plot
line because they're doing it just feels
like they're doing a pivot and they need
to wrap some [__] up so they can make
some room for whatever the new stuff is
gonna be yeah sure and then re-establish
that and let that breathe and so like
having to do
this in I don't know like there's an
interesting sort of contrast right now
we have to see the last episode but this
feels like it did kind of get kicked
into high gear or something after that
season break
and I don't know now whether to think
that those first five episodes were
conceived sort of in their own
particular span of time and these were
separated or something or what but like
there's something that does feel
very much transitional about what
they're trying to do here true true yeah
um no I don't know uh I'll go in with
the last episode with an open mind uh
but man most of the season's been a I
think most people like uh at least
people who have been watching the few
people have been watching the videos
with us here seems like most of you guys
have been enjoying it which I'm happy
for you guys I would never want to make
you guys not like something like our job
is just to share what our opinions are
and these are just our opinions and
we're not going to try to convince you
of what our as much as people call us
influencers I'm not going to try to
influence your opinion here uh and I'm I
wish that we felt more like what you
guys have expressed your feeling uh but
to me it's more like I'm in I enjoy
things intermittently and everything has
sort of been on a fine level but I think
the depth and impact of the storytelling
has greatly lost a lot of its substance
and it just has not changed in this part
too for me it's not adding much more
meaning to that bone and I think this
the the one with her wandering in the
desert was meant to uh convey some kind
of particular tone and and a deeper
connection to Siri here and again like
well I thought the acting was great
the episode in and of itself was a bit
of a slog and I guess it's supposed to
be his Vlog for her it was a bit of a
slog and then whenever we got actual
dialogue moments it was like this is
[__] so so generic uh even remember
even this [__] with the with the elf
girl like what a cool concept but damn
was that like the most generic ass
dialogue you get it was just
so generic and straightforward yeah yeah
like there's no umph to any of it and it
it was it's like oh yeah get these
actors to come back in these Visions but
I don't know like cool editing and
whatever like if you've seen anything
like this like this kind of Storytelling
of of isolated invisions and traumatic
facing the demons from your path it's
been done so many times and like there's
something you're a fantasy show you're
an Epic Fantasy show like do something
different here that you are too yeah
yeah like there's so many things you can
do yeah so
um yeah uh it's fine it's fine
everything's fine everything's fine and
it's fine to pretty cool we will watch
the last episode I always start these
hoping that it's gonna be great I don't
come here hope like it makes my life
more enjoyable if I can just enjoy it
obviously like I don't wanna you don't
want to sit here wondering why this
isn't working I don't want to dislike I
don't want to sit here for 40 minutes to
an hour just [__] like upset or bored
you know yeah I'd rather be here that's
like I'd rather be here enjoy myself uh
so I I want to go in liking something
you know so I'm really trying dying yeah
but it's just the show itself was giving
me is I'm like animal like I'm checking
out and and I don't even my morbid
curiosity of Liam Hemsworth is making me
go I don't think I ever want to see it
honestly looks like it's like I feel
like I'm done with this show after the
last episode that's just where I'm at
after after the last episode of this I'm
like I don't really care to see the Liam
Hemsworth one because this whole season
has been making me lose it this you know
well yeah and and you know for whatever
casting changes what's gonna happen with
the writing moving into that new season
yeah and if that writing is not getting
any better then I don't care uh plain
and simple I I don't care and I will
watch a Liam Hemsworth clip on my own
yeah yeah
um who knows maybe that one clip will
bring you back yeah [__] it um but guys
what have you been thinking about
Witcher season three have you been
enjoying it leave your thoughts down
below uh did you really like these last
couple episodes uh be honest just please
be honest it's all we ask is honesty is
the best policy uh but before we go
let's end this with a patreon
John you know what to do Chase Gardner
you're a real unicorn my friend when you
showed up we were like wow the heavens
have blessed us with this mystical
creature of great import and symbolism
and we will follow you through the
desert of patreon and Beyond into the
algorithms that hold the keys to our
Destinies and I feel like if anybody
could like give us some kind of
spiritual emotional hallucination pep
talk bring our spirits up it's probably
you you're often popping in on patreon
shows with enthusiastic but
straightforward comments and if anything
happened in this episode chances are it
was pretty straightforward that's the
perfect middle ground for you my friend
so uh hey be careful out there don't get
gored by any mystical creatures so that
we have to you know like smoosh a
bandage on you and call it a day but
either way bud thank you for your
continued love and dedication over so
much time it actually kind of blows my
mind the further we get you know the
fact that you're still here and you
still have that same enthusiasm I
remember from when you joined so be well
my friend we'll catch you next month
catch you next month buddy